hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to sport will not
started creating our next monstrosity so
here we go wait it to it take it away
all rights going with it we agreed that
we needed some fundamental change yeah
we need to change things there were some
proud of therefore one we don't have
arms like that's true and are the spikes
necessary that back butthole I is that
necessary probably not I love all the
things go ahead ok that saved a lot of D
inhave oh that was true we need he's got
the gangster lean the whole time like go
to the gun show oh can our hands be our
feet cute and they reach the ground
you just took its foot off that's pretty
good oh I mean it's almost perfection I
think it means more definitely needs
some more we got some more to spend
first of all much longer here and a
little farther back on that just got the
blood out there second of all this it's
it's almost it's oh good wait no it's
not good yet there oh yeah like really
relaxed really wait there just calm
[Music]
[Laughter]
yes they're facing the right way
[Music]
[Laughter]
that is the
[Music]
we gotta learn to spit okay
I focused on the task at hand
oh you like to take a breathe oh they
look very strong they look very well we
didn't put any actual practical stuff
our credo we'd done sighs our Hockett
launcher of course are our nipple
launchers or nipple launchers are pretty
impressive yeah oh okay hey hey you shut
up
we did val is very quick we have like no
skin so all of our flesh is just expose
only party mechanisms or our little
mouth bye bye sir what is that we have a
weapon we have a weapon we're
unstoppable we're gonna wheel back
okay that works
wait weren't there things over here
there were weak at one point what is us
whew something we can kill that I don't
want to go after the Alpha baby oh all
right then
fire fire fire again you can do both
[Applause]
good wait
[Music]
man you don't stand a chance I'm gonna
put my big bulbous on but on your buddy
oh man I can't wait to nom on Yugi but
we are eating him from the mins of it it
tastes much better from the butt alright
what about that guy oh yeah you're doing
good over here oh yeah we're gonna eat
you like wait you're wrong we made in XP
C's extinct now we're gonna go home and
[ __ ] not us by me we're gonna go home
and make a baby I'm doing a joking you
ruined my door northern well that mean
it's stupid now cuz you're an ass I was
watching our sexy gallop shut up chop
chop we're gonna bang with um Peugeot
god they're way too happy to see us
oh do you like my body and/or my nipples
[Music]
okay bye I guess does she enjoyed it
he enjoyed it we enjoyed it that's good
that's good right there that's true love
right there that's true love we can
actually put your self
wait okay that that's great right there
that's great I can see how you would
like that I I believe that you don't
want a knee pad no no I I believe knee
pads would be good but also
no no all's balls we don't need we need
that yeah I like I like where you were
going with this but I I have a I have a
vision
okay can I could do good that's good
definitely definitely definitely make us
more competitive oh good and we need to
be yes so in all honesty like we put
those under breast plates and have the
nipples on top yes I like what you're
going with this and also these broken
wrists
oh my god oh why would you flipped
upside down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're gonna do anything else to it slab
fifty-fifty we got one of those what is
this now we already got the balls for
striking you don't need those okay you
you you've put the finishing touches on
we always wanted to stay true to our
roots and remember that the dunk is
exactly what we want to add wasn't
Herman
oh we can fly tiny hitting baby there we
go like a butterfly oh no he's not 25
left Jesus uh we have so much what legs
or not no we don't want legs we can't
afford loose load legs are a luxury okay
honestly we can't afford we can get
different hands I guess Oh what about
the claw grab hands
those look good bone ticklers bigger
small God these don't screw anything up
of this masterpiece
[Laughter]
okay Nicolas wrote a no cheap would
screw up a tickly other scanners at the
same hour now heat skin's class okay we
need to actually see when this comes out
of the paint shop see this bad boy we're
going to Pete or pause not be heat press
for her you're in social stance right
now learn to strike press three oh yeah
I think we used our balls
I think this is one finger one finger we
needed next time
exactly let finish the speech it's
another thing I can throw I'm gonna get
emboss hey would you put me around it
side step I was trying to size the bill
inside sweet hey you run away from me
don't run away don't run away
walk ya favor spit up take that what I
don't know what we're doing though come
on we're really effective the kid is
very effective
I am shocked at how effective we're
moving in for the kill
next target lined up
[Music]
we're gonna be so smart smart brainpower
brainpower you've grown a little smarter
and taken your first step towards
sentience you have learned the ability
to entice an ally to join your pack and
help you on your adventures good good we
wanted to recruit our fellow whatever we
ours yes we tickle scrotes
the tickle scrote army place go tase no
the tickle scrubs army can I rename the
markup lights or whatever you by myself
if we're gonna be the tickle scrote army
from now on I like it tickle the scrotes
if everyone on YouTube until they join
our spiders Channel and our army to take
over the world
tickle scrotes unite and this will be
our handshake I think okay anyway so now
the bad nightmare is over
we've been going long enough to end this
day I think we've been going long enough
to end this nightmare we're gonna we're
gonna go if we need to find more parts
so we're just gonna go around and catch
up bars I know something why are we why
are we cheering more than usual I don't
know our balls are quivering eyeballs
are just seeing everything can't you go
faster what is that Oh
[Applause]
don't you dare bite our bow oh so anyway
let's go make another horrible creation
yeah we got a lot of DNA we could really
get creative we're on our way
fastest we can go boys and sweet Oh God
the ladies home shaking with excitement
jump yapper space jump no pressing home
ok no ok nevermind over this ma'am it's
panic president jumping around hey
there's only one other one here I'm
guessing the other one jumped off of
[Laughter]
switching Li stop twitching please I
think it's bugged three please just me I
think it's bug huh I'm trying to bug
well those eggs Oh the other exhaust get
some babies out of the way we're gonna
make love in front of them very did we
already did the sex don't think that
group bigger but leader sorry
something's done I really want to know
what you've done well too bad it's gonna
wait till the next episode so thank you
all so much for watching spore hope
you're enjoying this horrifying
experience this has been weighed in me
invading your nightmares for the rest of
eternity so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always we will see you
in the next video
[Music]
Oh buddy